hey guys Ryan right here there's another
trailer for Batman Arkham Knight so
review these trailers so many times
already don't know how much more I can
say about this this is 2 minutes and 15
seconds called all who follow you let's
check this out PEGI 18
looks cool man
the people of Gotham medium
you will bring there to all who follow
you
Robin Nightwing
ouch dark days are here Batman
the prophecy has come true from the
ashes of Arkham City the fires are
raging and Gotham is burning
I can see that same fire in your eyes
before this night is through that fire
will consume me
how much
Wow I really like that trailer a lot
that was really cool I mean it wasn't
one of those trailers that's making it
like freak out the whole time I love
that how dark and haunting that trailer
was of so menacing you know one thing
I'm liking about these arc of my
trailers is that they keep showing us
more cinematic effect we have some
awesome gameplay trailers out for this
game but it's really cool to see how
they're really promoting the story in
the villain a lot let's watch it again
Peggy 18 then music 2 is [ __ ]
beautiful and the graphic design is just
amazing like I love the way Gordon looks
how there's so much despair and Wow
Gotham's Palio fire
you will bring death to all who follow
you will bring death to all like it's
showing all these main characters that
we all know and that it's wow I love
Nightwing man I wings my favorite
character next to back
they're all coming together to take Nate
I love how it's showing us that it's
more than just Batman that he has to
have a team assembled to take this down
that Arkham Knight dude dark days are
here Batman
the prophecy has come true
from the ashes of Arkham City the fires
are raging and guffy is burning nothing
like a good villain mana walking that
same fire in your eyes before this night
is through that fire will consume you
feels like a sci-fi horror
the teamwork that we're getting this
time
I love how it kind of has like that
apocalyptic v to music it's so chilling
yeah it does have like a really cool
Menace about it the whole time man that
looks very haunting and it looks yeah
man I got chills nipples again the nips
are hard I'm so down to play that game I
like the previous installments this one
I love how everything just feels like a
total war out everything's just coming
to chaos it looks like Batman really
does like I'm scared to play a little
bit because I get so engrossed in games
when I play them that I feel like I'm
that character and it freaks me out when
I play games like this so I'm excited to
play it's a feel that level of fear
actually and it feel like a badass when
I overcome it rating time I'm definitely
going to be playing Batman Arkham Knight
anyway guys thanks for talking me that
was out if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects you
follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter
Tyron 1 million subs me I just want
product placement I want to do as least
amount of work as possible baby and
Chester love the channel been wanting a
shut up for months ok
ello shoutout me and all my kids about
73 of them what no joke huh I have proof
oh I get it of why you have so many kids
look at this guy he's black so that
means he's hung like a horse and he
probably doesn't like to wear condoms
because let's face it condoms get in the
way of pleasure
condoms suck I never wear a condom
not once never will and it's a girl need
to be on birth control
not for Davey and Chester he prefers to
impregnate them Davey and I hope you're
73 children are doing ok I hope they all
have big penises and I hope your
daughters have big tits about a lot of
guys want a titty [ __ ] them I hope your
kids the brothers and sisters end up
having sex with each other just so it
causes a disturbing effect in your life
but it would make me laugh